I don't like that okay hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to pop
goes now this is a five nights at
freddy's fan game that came out about a
half a year ago or maybe closer to a
year now I'm not entirely sure but it
did have about a year's worth of work
put into it and after I just got done
with the joy creation story mode now
this one isn't free-roam as far as I
know in fact I know very little about
this game but I want to see these games
at people like put their heart and sweat
into you know the games that they really
really slave over for very few rewards
out of it you know they they don't they
don't charge any money for it and I
think that's very respectable about
these these indie games even if they are
a derivative of something like five
nights at Freddy's the fact that people
go out there and they put so much work
into it for nothing else than the love
of the universe like that's that's what
I really want to see out of it so I'm
gonna give this a gander and see what's
going on here I think it's more of
classical five nights at Freddy's
styling if I'm not too mistaken oh hi oh
oh hi you're near that's near that's
anyway the phone you have in your hand
it's usually used by kids during the day
for games or not but I've sorted out the
security application that only activates
during the night which is when you're
here obviously everything you'll ever
need for your job is ready to use go on
press some buttons you can check all the
rooms with said cameras that are
connected online hey first night on the
job I'm rambling a bit it's a lot to
take yes trust me when I say I know how
that feels your imagination might get a
tad bit out of control
stress does that to you but don't worry
you're completely safe here I've built
this place from the ground up to be one
of the most transparent honest and
safest places on earth like if you ever
stop feeling anxious looking out the
window or just you know I'm sure you've
already guessed by now that these are
our animatronic characters oh my
technology
honestly the name animatronic doesn't do
justice they're more like multi-purpose
robots they can be programmed to do
anything I can think of they've pretty
much run this place now of course again
they are completely harmless
they aren't physically capable of
hurting anybody
all night to set up a simple QA system
to go with your app when this call ends
you'll get to help explain whatever you
want colors and what's going on your one
arm there oh let me look out the window
ah that's relaxing I feel good about my
life and my choices good thing all
weasel where got me on the weasel way to
go with bow one bow out to victory land
where the why is there anything
happening
well that arms got me pick panicked so I
don't understand they have there's so
many buttons there's so many things to
look at
is someone there shut that down how
about this with the fan I don't know I
don't know what any of you is why is
there a 3d printer in every room look
that doesn't make any sense are you
gonna print more anima trauma on demand
is it completely self-sufficient like
that oh what a nice window with a weird
chica looking thing in the whatever that
is not my dog chica that's the evil tiga
oh hi okay alright well you just feel I
don't know what to do about that so I'm
just gonna ignore it what even what even
do am I gonna die hey alright something
I don't know what it was but I heard
some honk honk honk honk honk ah good
window good I don't think it's a window
at all
feels like a goddamn oh it is a window
because that's relating dude oh ho
that's you
ah relaxing there's one thing that makes
me think of its how relaxed I am right
I think it's gonna be a relatively calm
first night but I have no idea what to
expect out of this because nothing makes
sense God if they went for like a more
complicated routine on all this [ __ ]
than boy how do they do it and I don't
like the presence in there that reminds
me the puppet heat this vent up I guess
you know that's it's not so much heat
that's kind of lasers it's gonna slice
them apart is that what you're gonna be
doing about it I don't know
goodbye I guess alright why'd you leave
ok see ya around the bend then alright
toodles toodles doodles doodles mr.
weasel cuz pop goes that and you yeah
alrighty then
I supposed to take from this so he
didn't actually leave you trying to oh
oh that's what he's doing he's building
something back there
no no he's building but I don't think
it's good so I don't know where he is
you above me I don't know how anything
can kill me I don't know where it's
coming from I don't know what I'm doing
with my life why am I doing this why why
why am I here what led to this point
where this was my job where I'm
surrounded by a bunch of animatronics
that aren't don't need any humans so why
would they need me to look over them it
probably just beat the [ __ ] out of
anybody that tries to break in here who
would break in here why is there
security in the first place that's like
the best question why why would there be
security in the first place in any of
these Lia facilities if you think about
it who's gonna break in they're gonna
die no one is there time wait oh God
alright well for I am so either my
imminent death is approaching me or I
get to contemplate my own mortality a
little longer I don't like that well
that's not good I don't like the lights
go on flicky funky you want to go away
how's it okay oh okay alright hey hey
what's up buddy how are you oh did I
catch you it okay alright then sorry
about that I am you catch you at a bad
time
whatever you say you know this is
holding that like yeah whatever okay
Jesus
all right
[ __ ] so what do I do
it's 5:00 a.m. we're almost out of here
you back there oh there's another leg
for some goddamn reason you just step in
and out to build your little Oh No boo
doo doll of me and then give it a nice
back rub so I can feel good about myself
maybe give it some posit
hi okay I don't like that Wow
was I supposed to do to prevent that now
what could I have done I'm thinking
nothing oh [ __ ] who was that
what happened what happened all right
whatever I go back in he was like some
shadow bonnie bonnie okay I think what I
think I understand what he was doing he
was going to these various 3d printers
going in and out like so that he could
make the pieces to get the bonbon me
staring at him didn't do a ding damn
thing me staring at him did a whole lot
of nothing wait what was that
oh hi Freddy what are you doing here we
shut down thank you whatever you do know
he lied to you who lied to me are you
talking about I'm panicking Oh No okay
ah nice window ah good relaxing oh there
you are hey know how many times I got
shut down that goddamn room how about
you be no put up heat on that room Oh
put some sheet on that yeah Oh what you
got for Ted to all [ __ ] oh no oh you
dad not you dad you dad we think we care
well shut up who did that panicking here
I'm so panicked whoa what the [ __ ] was
that
do you guys hear something
oh hey no I'm the birthday room you
don't go me Megan a new birthday party
what was that was that just a
combination of noises that I already
heard or was that something else
hi I see you in there were you going you
own the art room oh well that's a
mistake because I got my eye on you I
don't know what these colors do but know
which go huh which way you all no no no
you're not getting it this time I got my
eye on you
and I know exactly what you do even
though now I'm a seriously I don't have
as much time as I had before because I'm
stupid oh I see you always go well no so
this seems easy then I just got to
relieve my stress by looking out this
pitch-black window where anybody could
be literally staring into me because if
it's bright in here that means it's
everyone could see me pretty much right
oh no not the van not the van not too
bad not too bad oh there we go Earth Day
room huh where's that oh there he is
oh I it's not so bad so it's a whole lot
of this right that's it I can deal with
this you do this this is easy I got this
oh we will kill you why will you kill
you me why would you do that I don't
want a kid I know let me look out the
window house sure was startling calm
down COO you what ice princess we got
frozen over here we don't even hear that
whoa what are you how are you you're a
nice why were you ice I don't even
remember what you said
okay 3:00 a.m. doing all right not too
shabby
not too bad okay we're at 5:00 a.m.
which means that we should be getting
through this because I think if I'm not
mistaken this thing is this game is
gonna introduce like one concept at a
time so when it comes to these colored
buttons I don't know what they do with a
pig button over here I don't know what
that does hey what was that it was a new
sound is that the same sound with me
screaming like a little [ __ ] over
because I can never tell the difference
also what the hell's going on with above
me like what am I gonna do if something
is above me like how am I gonna stop
that I don't exactly have a way to stop
that unless it's that button on the side
there no according to the colors of the
rainbow
[ __ ] off Oinky Oinky Oinky pop goes the
[ __ ] you alright where the heck yeah I'm
not gonna panic sir don't tell me what
to do you being out there and somehow in
here at the same time I don't like that
but it's got to be over pretty soon
different I can't tell is that a pig or
is that a weasel is that what a weasel
looks like inanimate romoff or I don't
know but I'm almost done gonna hold on
for a little longer so why were they
making shadow Bonnie like that's a
completely other story and why would I
need to go look outside like I could
look outside right here it's not like
that caused me to panic any less oh my
god this [ __ ] staring me right in
the face oh no you don't I haven't let
you get a single piece of that shadow
Bonnie [ __ ] not about to start now
oh you ladies up there gonna help out or
not huh yeah that's right stay there
go away hey you alright okay well we got
that so that's good
well it's happening here oh well I mean
in someone's stomach what is this I
don't like that all right and what am I
Who am I so we're gonna like dark chica
this chicas dark name uh uh dark persona
maybe where we going oh you were
crystallized or frozen noir or something
I don't fully understand what balloons
great where the hell am I going why the
hell am I going there and what is
happening to me I don't know I don't
think I want to know depending on where
we are and why we're here this is what
the inside of an animatronics brain
looks like
probably yeah oh no is that balloons
boys clothes he's naked somewhere oh oh
you man oh hi okay bloom boy that was I
just realized that was your hat not your
claws I mean your ass fart your clothes
but whatever all right then second night
what are you gonna tell me
also I'm gonna die and skip this because
dive or whatever all right what do you
got for me a heat vent to stop noise oh
this sticky note he's gone already okay
I'll see ya toodles then oh just pick up
the goddamn phone
yes No
oh and I'll let you know now don't stop
sucking off I'm paying attention after
your first week is done are we doing a
review of your his name is for me you
[ __ ]
who lied to me
who did who you talking about I don't
know what you're doing
ah right bullet can't even [ __ ] we will
kill you great okay where is he stop
blocking my goddamn view soles oh great
oh I'm panicked oh well connection lost
eh okay well anyway that is pop goes I'm
probably gonna try to get lit at least
through like the five main nights if
that is what it is because this isn't
called five nights at pop goes this is
called pop goes so we're gonna see what
this game is all about later on so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]